[Musique]
j'adore quand gilles râle mais j'aime
quand général en pleine possession de
ses moyens
et j'aime pas quand il y sort de tous
tout de jouer deux ou de marionnettes
avec des tués de la folie elle était
passagère mais avec vous le foutage de
gueule et les permanences mais c'est
intolérable
riez riez riez penaud pas tolérable est
ce qu'on veut déboulonner notre idole
qui souffrent et 15 lots participerait
de hors jeu le label isation pierre dans
le pire moment pour moi ça a été toute
la séance d'hypnose avec gilles dallaire
signal d'alerté anti jeu reprend les
commandes se reprend les commandes entre
soi la manette sera automatiquement
réveiller on met les mains devant le
pacifique et la hawaii détention on sent
la barre haut en parachute
elle a été frappée avec une belle
énergie
j'avais l'impression qu'ils n'étaient
pas mettre complètement leur destin leur
parole de leur leur attitude et j'ai
trouvé que c'était assez déplaisant et
du cou particulièrement désagréable et
ça j'aime pas
[Musique]